I just heard loudness almost like
thunder
torch is still on fire we're being
thrown in our direction to our group
with their Shields I heard the sound of
metal hitting bodies
Robbie call me out of the blue and said
you want to sue the Nazis with me
I've been a litigator in New York City
for more than two decades
Charlottesville it actually shocked me I
wanted the toughest possible people to
help to expose that this wasn't really a
conspiracy it wasn't some sort of freak
accident where this car ran into people
there was overt planning how to prepare
for violence and make this appear as if
it's self-defense the threat that this
poses in this country we cannot not
fight back
we are working with victims of real
trauma it gives me like cold chills to
know that I'm gonna have to hash out
what happened
but this is important we're gonna speak
up we're gonna resist
need to prove the intent was to commit
violence and unite the right in order to
do that you need to elicit evidence
about their views do you consider
yourself a white supremacist no I don't
um
we are talking about some of the most
well-known white supremacists in America
they almost treat it like a game if I
did say that either I was lying then or
I was joking it was kind of like
litigating against Teenage violent
truance
it's a photograph of a red hat that says
make lynchings great again did you post
that I have no requests I'm not sure
what you're getting at yes locker room
talk stop it there stop
we found a flurry of communications
I mean I think what we would say is
there's bombshell after bombshell these
views are not just hateful and racist
but they are so explicitly violent which
is the key to our case
this is not just about what was in
mid-august 2017. this is about what
would be in America for many decades to
come
thank you